One thing we know about the stress response, is some of the effects it has on
the brain. If you remember from lesson three about the brain, or even our
memory lesson, we know that it's important for learning and memory. In fact,
the hippocampus has a large number of receptors for cortisol, which again, is
the stress hormone. We see the stress-related release of cortisol can cause
dendrites in the hippocampus to shrink. Now, if you remember from Lesson three,
dendrites are what come off of a neuron to collect information. This shrinkage
can interfere with several types of memory. Moreover, we see that stress can
decrease the amount of neurogenesis. So, new neural growth in the hippocampus,
which in turn inhibits synaptic plasticity, which will interfere with learning
and memory. So, in short, stress is bad for learning and memory.